soros which we know the name soros
here's what soros said recently and i'm
curious to get your take on
uh this soros is a guy that's worth i
don't know 20 billion guy he's a guy
that is
hated by the right and a lot of people
on the right think he is manipulative
deceptive and he wants to inject his
philosophies politically to this country
but here's what he said he says this is
a bloomberg article soros says china's
real estate crisis omicron threatens
rule billionaire philanthropist george
soros and china's xi jinping may fail to
extend his rule of the country later
this year
contrast to what most observers expect
sorority enemies within the party real
estate crisis ineffective vaccines and a
failing birth rate as factors working
against him internal divisions in china
are so sharp that it has found
expression
in various party publications soros said
she is under attack from those who are
inspired by deng xiaoping's ideas and
want to see a greater role for private
enterprise what do you think is going to
happen with g and china
well my sense of it and i'm definitely
no expert is that
it's not easy for the chinese to
maintain
internal unity
and so they tend to focus on that and
perhaps that's partly why china hasn't
been as expansionist to power as it
might have been maybe that's changed to
some degree in recent years but it's
it's a very large country it has an
incredibly diverse population and so
they have their own problems their own
internal problems which are significant
and and preoccupying and so
i hope that
they stay focused on their internal
problems and that they stay focused on
solving them china
has been
forward-looking enough thank god
to allow
the free market enterprise
to flourish
despite
the proclivity for implementing top-down
radical left state solutions
and the consequence of that has been
first of all now china is a player
in the international scene for better or
worse i think mostly for better i know
that a lot of that was
accomplished on the backs of the
american working class and that's
catastrophic in many ways but the fact
that
there aren't tens of millions of chinese
people starving
that's really good thing for
international security and stability and
that's of no trivial benefit to the
american working class as well and the
fact is that china makes a lot of cheap
stuff that works mostly
and that
people who are more stressed
economically have also benefited to that
to a tremendous degree so
it seems that
all of that has been good
the
twist towards a more totalitarian
mode of governance in the last 10 years
that's obviously extremely worrisome
the fact that china
is a totalitarian state has had a very
negative consequence on us in the west
especially
in the
immediate
uh what would you call it in the
immediate emergence of the of the
pandemic because what we did was we
rushed to imitate a totalitarian state
we thought chinese lockdown we better do
it it's like really
really we better do what the ccp did
well that's what we did and we'll see we
don't know what the consequence of that
is yet we'll see not good
not good
in my estimation and certainly the johns
hopkins studies
study
seems to
it's only a partial study in some sense
they've done the cost benefit analysis
costs so far we have no idea what the
costs are of having kids in masks for
two years we have no idea what the
consequences are
what that's done especially to
introverted kids who are high in
negative emotion because they're going
to be looking for a reason to hide
anyways and
who knows what that's done to their
psychological development both as
children and as adolescents we'll find
out over time
but we haven't paid the price for the
pandemic lockdowns even a little bit yet
did we destroy our economy
like these things take a long time
you know they say if you're piling an
oil tanker and
you detect an iceberg in your path you
can see it you've already hit it
because it takes so long for you to turn
that it's too late well in some sense
these huge systems that we're a part of
are like that is that
you can't tell when they're broken
because they take a long time to fall
over and i don't know if our system is
broken but
we're going to find out
and i don't know if the pandemic
lockdowns broke it and maybe they didn't
and hopefully they didn't i mean i was
in new york city
in manhattan a month ago
and it was the first time
i'd really gone out anywhere other than
toronto
and i'd been to new york a few years
before and it's a bouncing place
manhattan i love new york it's such an
amazing city you know the fact that
manhattan can even exist is just an
ongoing absolute miracle
seven million people compressed onto
that island and it's it's pretty damn
clean and it's pretty safe and it's
really cool and there's something to do
all the time and you can walk around
free and like that bloody place is a
miracle that's for sure
and it looked pretty good
i thought isn't this something these
people have been locked down for like 18
months and this place isn't on fire
it actually it's pretty clean and most
of the businesses are still open and
isn't that a bloody miracle and which it
most definitely is
and so let's pray and not be too
resentful about all the foolishness
let's pray that
we
wake up and we
treat the pandemic like the flu and we
get back to something resembling the
normality of florida and
we put this behind us and we don't get
too upset about january 6th and we don't
get too vengeful about the democrats and
the radical left and we licked someone
half sensible to run the republicans and
we
carefully weave our way through to a
peaceful future we let's pray for that
because the alternative is pretty damn
dismal and i don't think we have to have
the alternative
you know one of the we talked about
trump earlier
here's my dilemma with trump
one of many
um
he's beating the election with stolen
drum pretty damn hard
and i look at that as an outsider again
because i'm canadian and i think
well you americans you've been split 50
50 for like five decades like right down
the middle and there's always
election
trouble
because no system is a hundred percent
perfect maybe there's like a one percent
two percent margin of crookedness
something like that and
you're probably really not going to get
rid of that maybe you can
maneuver carefully to keep it so that
it's never any more than one or two
percent
but to get rid of that last bit of
malfeasance and deception and corruption
would take such a heavy hand that that
would become worse than the problem
and
that's a real problem when you split 50
50 because small election irregularities
can throw the whole election
okay so
it isn't obvious precisely what can be
done about that but
the election was stolen narrative i
think it's weak for a variety of reasons
the first is
it's pretty whiny
like why didn't you win with five
percent margin then
so how do you know this isn't your fault
and you think the republicans aren't
gerrymandering congressional districts
because they are
and so it's not obvious that even if it
is the case that there is
substantive election fraud that it's all
from one side
and so there's that and then
you're sure that's the message you want
to be sending people that they shouldn't
have faith in their most fundamental
institution
you might be right but
but
it's in your interest for that to be
true
and so that's a moral hazard
and then
well what happens when you retake the
house because that's what's going to
happen i think the democrats going to
get stomped in the in the upcoming
election
are those elections somehow valid but
yours wasn't and so
why magically when the republicans get
elected that's honest but when they
don't it's not and so doesn't that take
the wind out of your story it's like
well it was stolen well you have the
house and the senate
how do you account for that so that to
me that that's going to weaken that
narrative trump is capitalizing on anger
he's using the election issue as a means
to an end and he may believe it
but it doesn't matter because it's a
weak story especially when the democrats
lose the house it's a weak story so it's
not gonna it doesn't have any momentum
but then it it's worse than that
because i also think and i've talked to
lots of republicans about this
is that the best story you've got
you've got tradition on your side
you've got the truth as an adventure on
your side you've got belief in truth on
your side that's been abandoned by the
radical left
you've got belief in science on your
side
you've got responsibility on your side
you've got the fundamental purpose of
higher education on your side
you can't conjure up a better story for
americans than the election was stolen
with all that on your side
that's just not
very impressive
and i have sympathy for politicians in
general
in the united states
congress people have very hard jobs it's
not a job i would like
i don't think it's a pleasant job
they spend a lot of their time
fundraising 25 hours a week on the phone
out of their congressional offices
because otherwise they're not supported
by their party leadership
forty percent of them sleep in their
offices when they go to washington they
don't even have apartments those that do
usually have little bitty apartments
their families aren't there because it's
hard to get families to move to
washington now with dual career families
they don't have much of a social group
they have to
run for their job every two years
this is not a plus they're under attack
all the time and they're micromanaged
and micro scheduled so
i'm curious what point are you trying to
make are you trying to make a point with
trump saying the fact that you know
election was stolen because that's
exactly what hillary clinton's position
was for four years that elections were
stolen from her better no better when
she does it oh no i'm not even what i'm
trying to say is i looked at it as a
weak position he's a weak position it is
a weak position she was taken i think
okay but that's the worst of it it's
like really where are you going with
this are you going with the better story
tell a better story if you want to get
reelected is that no no no no no no
the way to re-election is through a
better story but that's not the reason
to tell it
the reason to tell it is because you
believe it and the for the first time in
my life really i believe this to be the
case conservatives really have something
to sell to young people
and they have the they can sell the
meaning of responsibility
because young people are bereft of
meaning
and most people find meaning and
responsibility
and and when the right talks about
responsibility they kind of do it in
that finger-wagging way that makes
conservatives unpopular among young
people you should be responsible it's
like yeah you should
why
well
because your life is chaotic and
meaningless and you're stuck in this
juvenile surreality
and
it's really painful for you and you're
anxious and aimless and goalless
and then you look at people who have a
life because maybe you could have a life
and you think well what does that life
consist of it's like well you have a
committed intimate relationship there's
one
you have friends that you're honest with
and and playful with so you have a group
of friends you have a job or a career
you know you
you learn how to use your life your time
outside of work in a productive engaging
way you regulate your susceptibility to
the multitude of hedonistic temptations
that are in front of you
you
pay some attention to your mental and
physical health you make a goal some
goals for the future that are concrete
well there's seven things you can do
they're all responsible things why
because then your life will have some
meaning now you might say well what's
the ultimate meaning it's like get those
things straight first
they're not nothing and maybe you won't
be so damn miserable and bitter and
resentful and angry and aimless and
anxious and frustrated and disappointed
and ashamed if you had
five of those seven things going well
and the conservatives can make that case
no bloody left isn't making that case
it's like for them responsibility is
pretty much equivalent to totalitarian
patriarchal oppression
the conservatives could just take that
say no no our institutions they're
pretty solid
maybe if you don't like what's happening
on the political front you join
a group a church
the elks the rotary
some civic organization get in there and
do your part why not because you should
even though you should but because
well why not meet some people who are
like-minded and have a social group
you think biden can can have the kind of
impact to push people away from the
political party to the opposing side
similar to how goldwater and what they
did back in the days on how
civil rights was handled when
barry goldwater did what he did and next
you know african-americans went from
only 60 percent
of them voting
democrat to 92 percent four years later
they went from 60 to 92 percent four
years later next election and
republicans haven't had a chance on the
african-american vote since 1964. do you
think the current climate is that big of
a climate where the conversion from one
side to the other side to say listen i
don't agree with you guys on censoring
if the guys want to talk leave them
alone the way you handle kovit by
shutting everybody down i don't agree
with that constantly printing money i
don't agree with that do you think it
could be something where it could flip
that that big
i don't know because 20 the next
presidential election in this climate is
a long way away because you know who can
predict the future even a year out
especially given the rate of
technological change that we face now i
mean you don't even know what's
happening today there's so many
technological transformations just today
many of which have world shaping
consequences god only knows where we're
going to be by the time of the next
presidential election but
it certainly does seem to be the case
that the democrats are going to lose big
in the fall
and so you know that's that's what we'll
focus on for the time being so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]